es una de las zonas sísmicas más activas
del mundo la placa tectónica de anatolia
hace contacto con la arábiga y cuando
hay una serie de fuerzas que vienen del
interior de la tierra la corteza se
rompen distintas zonas generando fallas
en el caso de este terremoto de Turquía
y Siria esto ha pasado en la placa de
anatolia que se mueve en dirección oeste
y aunque la mayoría de sismos anteriores
se producían en la falla norte de
anatolia que han llegado a destruir
Estambul en esta ocasión ha sido en la
falla Oriental la causante en estas
fallas se generan grandes terremotos
porque son zonas de fricción de ahí su
frecuencia así lo analizó el geólogo
Jesús Ibáñez para France 24
evidentemente siempre se van a volver a
repetir se sabe que hay terremotos
hablante terremoto más grande del año de
1930 pero el año 70 también hubo en la
zona norte también hubo y es un problema
también pues de las autoridades velar
por sabiendo que haber terremoto por la
seguridad de de la población pero es un
problema también económico y importante
que ocurre en todo el mundo
pese al conocimiento y a la posibilidad
de que en cualquier momento haya esos
terremotos no se hace lo suficiente para
prevenir mayores daños
sobre todo primero invertir es decir que
la autoridad es sean capaces de bueno
ver cuál edificio se construye Hay un
problema de autoconstrucción Hay un
problema de corrupción es decir cuando
no se pone la cantidad de hormigón o
cuando no se sigue las normas Turquía
oficialmente tiene una de las normas y
más resistentes más importantes del
mundo lo que estamos viendo aquí ahora
que nos está siguiendo luego con
respecto a la población ocurre lo mismo
es decir cómo actuar cuando ocurre un
terremoto o incluso ver dónde estamos
viviendo no que eso es algo importante
evidentemente no podemos elegir cuando
nuestra situación económica no lo
permite según la autoridad de gestión de
desastres y emergencias de Turquía el
país registró más de 22.000 sismos en